drag Club bikes is a whole new
experience to drive club introducing
staggeringly fast and agile super bikes
racing in the drive of the universe on
beautiful tracks at day and night all in
the connected and social world of drive
Club where I grew up we used to see them
under Man TT every year so big challenge
for me was to really get that sense of
excitement and noise enjoy club bikes
multiplier and drive the bikes is
awesome lots of opportunity to overtake
while some opportunity to show off for
wheelies if you pass each other over the
finish line right in with new clubs it
feels amazing
obviously it's fast paced it's close
action it's we also wheel it's
incredibly exciting on a powerful riding
on these amazing super bikes you've got
a whole new bike stall you've got new
challenges new face sauce a whole new
mold skill mode where you get to show
off wheelies stop piece and you know
play around on the bike a lot more than
you would do with a car which is great
fun you know when you're on a bike it's
all about hit placements you know
shifting weight back and forth or when
you're doing wheelies or stopping all
those sort of things really need to
build the character from ground up zone
put mall in new fancy leathers you know
customize the leather so they match your
team colors and of course the same for
the elements the club's in drive club
now includes bikes and cars and then
everything that you do when you're
racing in Drive look now on bikes on a
car whichever is that you want to waste
with you'll be earning more fame for
your club to be unlocking new rewards
together new events together and you'll
be able to get more out of play and
drive club with each other
drive club is a constantly evolving game
and drag the bikes is that next step
adding staggeringly detailed bikes from
the world's best manufacturers and it's
a completely new way to play drive club
we spend a lot of time analyzing the
bikes whether it's for audio so there's
this microphone placed all over the
bikes and put on racetracks and taken up
to the absolute top speeds and we record
every single sound pop
that they make and then yeah we do
exactly the same week we scan down to
the nearest millimeter we get all the
CAD data that the manufacturers give us
so if you know everything as close as
possible to physically be in correct
flow through the tracks and then chasing
down acquisition it's something that you
don't quite get with them driveclub and
the cars because cars big meaty things
and they're almost muscling the way
around the tracks where there's a
lightness of touch the bikes as they go
through and then when that transfers to
multiply you get big packs weaving in
and out of each other and it gives a
really good multiplier experience so
yeah it's that sense of flow that's
really different from car for the
players